[Music]
hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we want and today
on ask an expert segment we got ron
professional mma fighter here
hello a question i wanted to ask because
you also have a kid
a lot of people that are like in the nfl
or pro fighters
like they actually don't want their kid
to do the exact same thing that they did
because of like head trauma or whatever
how do you feel about stuff like that
i'm okay with that uh for my kid if he i
mean he looks like he kind of likes it
already because he's already in the gym
like he's already hitting the bag like
he's already grappling he's already been
in the [ __ ] out of the other babies how
old is he oh he just turned two
but it's it's weird he's weird like he's
really fast and he's really strong
and so like we had him play with another
two-year-old his age and he just like
grabbed him like come play with him and
the kid like flew i was like
this is bad you want to like yes no
because i'm like oh no
like he's gonna get on timeout right now
like he's gonna have no friends
do you think the other guy's dad he gets
his ass kicked all day long
and then he sees this kid getting his
ass kicked and he's like that's
[ __ ]
like son that's my little kid yeah
i mean yeah because i've seen you like
after a fight
like your hands swollen your shin your
knees like you have bruises everywhere
um for you it's like that's it's all
part of the fun it's all part of the
sport like you don't mind your kid
getting beat
up like that yeah or even being exposed
i mean i think when he was like
one i took him to we drove him to san
diego and he watched a muay thai fight
like cage side
it was pretty cool mine yeah i was
fighting that was my my last one
do you think he understood what was
happening no but it's funny because he
just laughs
so you just see he sees me hitting
somebody i'm just like
that's daddy dude good thing he wasn't
there when you got knocked out like
these guys were
you're right he's gonna start pretending
to be me
hey dad look i'm you oh [ __ ]
imagine is that against you you're like
go clean your room like why oh this
could happen
i was like are you gonna knock me out
but yeah i don't i don't mind um for him
i'm i want to give him every
possible opportunity to kind of gear
towards whatever he ends up like kind of
liking yeah so we can introduce him to
everything we have drum sets
guitars like uh so early soccer balls
he's only two right yeah he's playing
with it dude with a soccer ball he can
dribble
it's freaking new he's like doing the
wrong sport with it with the foot with
the feet with the feet yeah
yeah we took him to a park he's like
dude i'm like dude our kid's gonna be a
freaking athlete don't get him into
soccer though please
the world doesn't need more soccer it's
so boring
he you guys had to move to a different
country
if he really picks up soccer yeah
because uh uh
american football i mean soccer sucks
right like we're not known
you know honestly i don't really watch
sports really oh you don't have time for
[ __ ] huh i'm weird yeah i
i don't watch tv really in there don't
watch me you don't watch ufc that much
um no unless uh unless it's like a big
card
or unless my teammates are on it so i
mean honestly sometimes with my
teammates i don't watch it
because i get updates through our text
groups like minute by minute i don't
watch sports either
i don't know why but why don't you watch
yourself please you don't watch your
sport though um no because i mean i do
it all day and night you know
um and so if i'm watching a sport
usually it's not for leisure like if
i'll go like if i go to bart's house to
watch the fight i'm not really going to
watch the fight i'm just going to hang
out with my friends
did you used to though watch it a lot
when you were first
getting into it like you were really
into it yeah i was into it and then
and then you know i just started doing
it and so that kind of gave me my fix
you know like when i watch when i watch
want to when i watch a fight now it's
more like studying tape than kind of
like watching like a like an
entertainment show i'm just like
and you kind of know too much too huh
like you know like
uh like let's say we write movies and
like in the beginning you're wowed by a
movie but then now once you can start
seeing the structure of the movie it's
like
you don't have the same exact enjoyment
like i feel like when i if i watch a
fight
i'm still getting wowed by it like crazy
for you you're probably seeing like all
the technical things
yeah i'm studying it's almost like i'm
watching i'm like studying homework you
know i'm like watching like cool cool
cool because i'm trying to use and copy
it
you know i'm like oh yeah heck oh i'm
gonna do that i'm gonna do that tomorrow
when you see a knockout do you feel the
same way we all feel we're like [ __ ] yes
oh yeah that that's that's that's primal
you know you see you're like oh
oh that's so fun i mean it's like
watching a nascar car crash you know
you're like
only thing i like about nascar yeah you
know it's just violence is entertaining
man
it is you know and so when you see the
the the most extreme level of violence
which
is rendering somebody unconscious like
when you see somebody like get hit
and you see like their soul leave their
body you know that's entertaining as
fudge
i'm like man when they just go like limp
like that one
fight with [ __ ] jake the jig falling
robinson oh my god i didn't see that
coming and all the memes that came
up i was like oh i was like oh yes you
see that i was like
this gotta suck and you think you'd be
okay with seeing like your kid like that
one day
oh no definitely not like i mean i'm
gonna train him to i mean or
as parents you want to make your kids
better than you and so my aim is to make
sure that
he never gets knocked out yeah twice by
the same fun
same kind of punch by the same punch but
it's a part of the game though
you know the consequence is way crazier
than
the reward no no no i don't want to say
that it's like a different one
from like golf or something like that um
yeah i mean it's it's subjective so
let's say like something like football
right um you
you ram in each other head to head all
the time you know whereas me i've sus
i've stuff in the 17 years i've done
this i've suffered one concussion
um i've had one torn acl and then one
and then a couple of muscles in my
shoulders is that pretty low compared to
what the normal uh injuries are yeah
it's not too bad i mean so in 17 years
i've sustained three serious injuries a
concussion
a knee surgery and a shoulder surgery
which isn't so bad considering
i'm putting my body through excessive
amounts of of wear and tear yeah i heard
like
just from so many people that were in
like sports just as athletes like from
high school on
and if they took it mad seriously a lot
of them have injuries like it's not
normal to have no injuries yeah it's
it's part of life you know it's like a
it's like a sports car
if you get a honda civic not a lot of
parts gonna wear out as fast as like a
nissan gt-r
like stuff's gonna wear out faster
because you're gonna drive it faster you
know
um and the same thing with uh with golf
you wouldn't think that golfing where
but tiger woods
swung so much you had to get hip surgery
because hip wore out
you know are you gonna be the type of
parent who's like um
you need to have a backup plan are you
like you can go all in on fighting if
you want to or whatever you want to do
i was taught a long time ago by uh by
all the role models i gather in life to
just go for the dream
you know you can make as much money as
you want but if you're not happy doing
it then
we're gonna do with that money you know
um you can buy all the cars and toys
that you want but if you're still
unhappy
you're just unhappy with toys and cars i
just don't get how people can do that
because i just want to sit on a beach
all [ __ ] day long and that would be
so sick
yeah that's the dream dude what's wrong
with that that's what i'm saying
i don't know how you could be unhappy if
you're just sitting on a beach all day
long you gotta you gotta be able to
afford that oh yeah
yeah i'm like if we all have the option
to not have to
just chill in the beach for the rest of
our lives and i have to worry about
bills heck yeah
but you know um yeah if you were born on
a beach then yeah yeah and
just like that like dude if i was born
in like uh
i was born in ecuador and i lived on the
beach in a hut and all i had to do was
just like fish and chill on the beach
all day that's a freaking life
i would say he has a better life than
most people here in america you know and
he probably makes like a dollar a month
like one of the surfers
back in the day in hawaii like he has a
story of like
you know this guy that was at a resort
and then he was like yo
how come you don't want to like make
more money and then
he's like why and he goes because like
then you can like retire do whatever you
want and
he's like like what he goes like get a
beach house and then like
you could surf all day and he goes i'm
doing that right now so he's like why
should i make more to do what i'm
already doing that's why i don't want to
ever go golfing because i don't want to
fall in love with it because golfing's
so [ __ ] expensive
no it's not that expensive i just
started i just started last week you
started yeah i just started what made
you start
um but my friends i work in the office
with they all play golf
and then so i spent a lot of time with
him and so i was like okay i guess i'll
play golf too
and then so i bought some clubs 200
bucks and i'm left-handed so that's like
harder to find what about club fees oh
it's like if you go to a driving range
it's like 20 bucks
to go to a driving driving range yeah
what about like don't you gotta like
rent like a car
you could drive it around yes if you go
to like the crazy bougie ones yeah those
are expensive you go to like a like a
normal person golf range
um i wanna do it with the trash though
okay well then you gotta find like the
friends that will get you in
they can get a friend in you know and
then tag along with them but it's it's
real it can be relatively reasonable um
yeah and you can get balls for like as
cheap as like a buck a ball
you know um and then really that's
that's it
what's fun about it it's weird do you
ever go to boat remember bullwinkles is
that a thing
boy or what's it called like mini golf
yeah yeah yeah
i like mini golf it's the funnest part
yeah like you ever go to those uh
batting cages you just hit the ball as
hard as you can it flies yeah that's
what i feel like it is with golf yeah
but i don't go
like i gotta go every single day every
day you know i just do like once
i like the driving range that shit's
fine like the hitting stuff like it's
like shooting
right yeah like what are you doing but
standing there like shooting bullets at
something
yeah like for hours on end that sounds
sick though yeah it's dope
you know and and i would say golf is is
similar because you're just
hitting a ball with a stick as far as
you can and then trying to put in a hole
i like the first part of that that's why
i think the driving range is really fun
yeah but
needing to see the ball go in the hole i
don't have that knee oh then just go to
the driving range
i think that's holding um and the
putting and stuff is just like the
details you have into it the mini golf
part
is like the mini golf details yeah
that's the details yeah let's say
driving range plus
miniature golf course that's golf i wish
regular golf though had the cool little
like houses that you can hit the ball
into or like the dragon's mouth and it
comes out of a butt
you know and like well maybe you should
do like a uh joe's 18
holes that would have been yeah i think
i'm gonna do that i think golf needs
something like that
like golf needs like an mma competitor
to come in and be like yo here's [ __ ]
golf
like the like someone that's loud and
causes drama yeah yeah and
and like you said it has dragon's
[ __ ] face that you got to get the
ball into and [ __ ]
what's the opposite of miniature massive
joe's massive golf
how about that so the golf ball is like
this big enough
yeah everything's big with dragons
yeah you can televise that [ __ ] that
sounds freaking fun can we make that
happen watching golf on tv
literally is one of the worst things
i've ever had to do with my grandpa
maybe you gotta really understand it to
enjoy all that stuff
yeah it's like it's like surfing if you
don't know surfing it just looks like
they're floating and turning on the
water
but they look sick though because
they're [ __ ] going like this
like you see someone hit her right and
then they just zoom out
and you can't even see the ball going
the air you don't even know what's
happening
and all of a sudden they zoom back in
and there's a ball that goes
like that and everyone's clapping and
everyone's kind of clapping
nobody's really going nuts either yeah
i think it's a sport of calm people why
is it only rich people that are into
that [ __ ]
you have to wear khaki pants to play
maybe we should have asked the real
estate cat
yeah why did you like it you came in
talking about golf and he's like i
[ __ ] rock at it actually so
oh my gosh but so far you've actually
i've spent a couple hours with you
you have sold me more on golf than
fighting maybe wear mma gloves while you
play golf
oh hit a golf club and then hit pads
get the pat get the golf club back on
hit another one dude drive ranging plus
pad hitting
that sounds fun when you when you have
people that come in and then you train
them
like do you know can you sense from like
a person's energy like oh you could be a
fighter on my eyes i can't be a fighter
i can sense if they're going to be good
at that or not um
how do you sense it uh just demeanor
their mannerisms
uh kind of just uh their work ethic
right to say like if they're already
um like even the coordination everything
like that but for me
like you can have as little talent as
possible but if you put in the work
you'll get good at it
like i i i've trained people that have
horrible coordination
horrible attention span um and like i'll
say right hand
onto your nose they'll be okay you know
um but over time if they put in the work
um they'll get right hand over your nose
oh we did it we touched the nose and
just even little things like that are
huge you know
um i got a guy that i train um and we're
working on just getting into a fight
stance
and because he's been in accidents and
whatnot he's struggling to like get that
that that neurological connection just
to stand just to stand in a fight stance
um you don't go like here's your money
back sir
well for me i i did this to make a
difference you know and i use fighting
as my vessel you know
so for some people getting a fight
stance is a major accomplishment you
know
like dude i did it my legs aren't
shaking like my legs are strong enough
to hold this position like
heck yeah all right now let's jab you
know next step
um and so like every you'll be surprised
man like uh
some people are more capable of people
uh more capable than others of the
smallest things
since you're a fighter and you like you
you analyze your opponent and [ __ ] you
ever just walk around the grocery store
and go i can kick that guy's ass that
guy's ass i could take that guy no
problem no but um when when danger rises
someone kind of has conflict whether
they
most of the time it's verbal um i can
kind of just look at their demeanor i
was like all right have you changed
anything or you just crazy confident and
a lot of times
they're mostly just crazy confident that
you can just tell by their body movement
like all this debt is not a fight at all
yeah yeah just the demeanor and
everything like that because anybody
that's like highly skilled in training
they have a demeanor they're they're not
like
you know what's up sup bro you know um
they you just act different you know
um when you're when you're experienced
in something you act differently than if
you're then you're new at it how do you
act like your experience like an act
like that
because i don't i don't i'm not i don't
have to ask you you go like be careful
you don't know what you want oh that's
good dang careful what you pay for
does that look like he knows what he's
doing you know all of a sudden develop
an accident you go be careful okay come
on
you got to do one of those joe gets
immediately knocked out
i dare you i dare you um i don't know
it's just uh i guess the confidence
of knowing that you're not you're not
any threat you know or somebody's not
anything
you're not in any danger there's no
danger um like
in front of any human being like i feel
no danger um
regardless of their size i mean even if
they're high level fighter i'm like
we're not going to go there you know
better you know if anybody is actually
poses a threat to me
then we both should know better than be
in the position when did that happen for
you because like
obviously everyone's scared first and
then if someone was yelling and
like being big you're kind of like oh
[ __ ] but then
at what point do you build that
confidence where you're like
i can kill you you know i would say
after my third or fourth fight like a
profile
pro amateur because honestly the
difference between ambition pro
um isn't that big i mean it's kind of
big but
at the same time it's not kind of it's
not that big it's probably the biggest
difference between
not fighting and fighting right that's
probably like yeah that's the biggest
gap but from amateur to pro
um the difference you'll see is for
whatever reason in the pro level you're
much more aggressive
um you guys just let it go much more
like
you'll see some intro fights and it
seems like they're like just barely
touching each other because they're kind
of timid
that's what the amateur leagues are for
but at a pro level they will try to rip
your head off
you know nose holds barred but at the
amateur level you can still rip
somebody's head off just some people are
more timid
and so there's a huge gap in like skill
and performance at the amateur level and
so you have guys that kind of like just
and then you have the same guy in the
ring though should be like
and then just try to like destroy them
um and so like for me i was
i was the other side of trying to
destroy people at the amateur level
and uh after my second or third fight i
was like i could do this like holy crap
like i could do and at the same time i
was uh i was a bodyguard too
and i was doing security so that really
solidified like hey can i do this to
like regular people
um because in security you can't hit
people you can only manipulate them
uh physically or with your words too but
um
i was able to control people and not
even lay lay one punch
so like i did security for seven years i
haven't i never punched one person nice
it's a guard like i mean that's why they
say verbal self defense
were they for like celebrities or like
rich people or um
it was for uh it was for nightclubs in
orange county and then
uh and strippers so walking them to
their car
uh yeah and then to the pole yeah yeah
they would do that they would do like
private shows and stuff like that
or like private uh shows yeah events
yeah
concerts yeah yeah let me rub on the
dick privately
and then it's like hey you're getting
too frisky there and you gotta come in
hey man
please remove one hand one hand policy
yeah that's okay you can touch that
um but yeah just uh but never
funny enough when when i was uh doing
security for like
exotic dancers and stuff like that zero
trouble it's when i was working at like
bowling alleys
um that's where all the tough guys show
up yeah the bowling alley dude i wanna
tell people at the bowling house
that's where i had the most fights not
bars i've been i've
i've uh i've bounced out bars and stuff
like that and i've had scuffles there
and whatnot but the bowling alley
was where i had the most trouble out of
all places that's why i heard what joe
rogan was talking about where he's like
think about how many fights that break
out at
a fight gym like zero yeah because
everyone knows how to right so there's
no
there's no incentive to like peacock and
puff your chest out because someone will
put you in a place immediately
but at like the place where you least
expect to where everyone's supposed to
be chilling
that's where like the people that like
have something to prove they'll come out
yeah try to prove something well there's
so much adrenaline in bowling though
dude
you don't know what it's like that's
ain't no gold it's freaking bowling
did you did you get um like you know
like
non-fighters they it's it's usually like
a size thing like a height thing or
like they're intimidated or not based
off of size do you feel like you have to
work
harder or something because for me that
was like me in high school i felt like i
had to work
harder because of my size yes i mean as
a as everyday life well i was lucky
because i'm
i i don't put a threatening energy to
anybody like i just well because of that
doesn't that work against you as a
bouncer
oh yeah definitely so they're like i
could [ __ ] this guy uh yeah every every
place i ever worked the first
the first week of every place ever
worked gave me the most trouble
because there's always regulars and they
always try to test me and so you know
what they do um let's see if i remember
one one is uh
i had to watch the exit door to make
sure nobody came through the exit door
or came in and out right so i'm just
standing there
and this guy walks out the exit door and
i stop i'm like hey hey man you can't
walk out there with that beer in your
hand yeah and he looks at me he up
looking down he's like
and then he continues the walk i'm like
hey hey he's like get your hands off me
bro
and i'm like you can't walk out with
your beer in your hand and then he's
like well you're going to take it from
me i'm like
i'll ask you one more time and i'm going
to remove the beer from your hand and
then he's like you're going to remove
this beer from my hand
and i'm like yes and so i put my hand on
the beer and he holds on for dear life
yeah and i'm like do you come here often
he's like
yeah i'm like i never seen you before i
was like i'm new i'm wrong hi
um like if i remove this beer from your
hand you're never coming back here i
will blacklist you and then his
girlfriend's like babe it's not worth it
what are you doing i just give them the
beer
he looks at me he's like you're lucky
bro
and then he let's go with it yeah he's
and then
uh he drops it and he's like thank you
i'm like now you can go outside was that
so hard
uh and then you said the art of
gentleness yeah yeah it's tight
because you have to calm these people
down yeah yeah um if i go no
you let go and we just escalated the
situation
yeah and then and then we're fighting
and then we're fighting yeah
yeah but part of my job is to
de-escalate the situation you know and
that's why they
one they wouldn't hire me if i walked in
on the street like hey can i be a
bouncer at your bar
i want to [ __ ] everybody up they're like
hi
you no you can do accounting though when
people do hear that you're a fighter
though i've heard this a lot that people
try to test you a little more like if
you're out
and about like drunk drunk [ __ ] no
not necessarily because it's not like
i'll go around announcing it like one i
don't even look the part
i just look like a regular asian dude
you know
um and so they'll test me the first week
but word will get around like hey don't
mess with the guy he knows kung fu
you know it's always the line you know
this guy knows kung fu and
funny enough the little guy you see at
any club they're working there because
they can do some damage usually guys are
big so if there's a little person there
it's because they can do something so
[ __ ] with the big guys is what you're
saying you do the pushovers yeah yeah
yeah um in fact every every place i've
ever worked um anytime there's trouble i
do the dirty work
uh when crap hits the fan they stand
there and they're like ron i'm like
come help me rock ling ling come help
i'm like okay
why is it because if the cops come they
suspect you too or no because uh
straight the big guys don't really
don't know don't know anything they
don't need to yeah they're refrigerators
if you're
if you're a big dude you don't have to
learn how to fight yeah you just pick
somebody
you just use your body like you go to
like a high security places like you go
to like
uh like rhinos gentlemen club in las
vegas
they are all like football linebackers
dude like
no one's starting to trouble there um
because they're huge and scary
they don't need people like me in there
uh because trouble rarely ever happens
but you go to a local club
guys aren't as big because they're not
going to pay them as much um that's when
you kind of test your boundaries like i
could you look at this i think i could
take him
i think i could take him he's only like
10 pounds on me dude they should put
bars in mma gyms
there would never be a [ __ ] fight
again and people would learn quickly you
know
you weed a couple guys out and they
would learn pretty quick you know there
have been mma
uh fights in bars though like with cages
inside of a bar as a show
that's freaking cool it's super like
like super like low budget like shows
like just put a pop up like a 10 foot
diameter
mma cage and you just have people fight
oh yeah there's a lot of underground
fighting too huh yeah there used to be a
whole lot more but then the commission
black black black ball did so if they
catch you doing an unregulated fight
they ban you from all professional
sports wow so
they don't do it anymore um but they
used to they would call smoker fights
you could literally just like yo
let's run some fights in here tonight
let's call some people
yeah and then fight club [ __ ] but now
like the commission will come in like if
they find out they will 86 you from any
professional event
wow and you won't get ranked you're not
getting real fighters in there ever
you're like in a like a black book or
whatever yeah you're in the black book
they they'll they'll black book you dude
it's crazy like it's it's like a it's
like a crazy organization
like you don't eff with them dude what
are the underground guys doing then
right now they're
[ __ ] huh i'm love ground baby oh yeah
that's good
there's actually a place they could
fight now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you